readings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by zip recruiter listen hiring is
challenging but there's one place you
can go where hiring is simple fast and
smart a place with growing businesses
connect to qualified candidates that
place is zip recruit accom slash church
zip recruiter send your job to over a
hundred of the web's leading job woods
but they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find the right people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job you understand what I'm trying
to say listen hiring is toughing up and
right now the church family can try zip
recruiter for free you heard that right
free right now right now go on
zip recruiter for free at cibecue
live.com slash Church that's zip
recruiter calm slash Church church CH
you are CH Robin Hood is an investment
app that lets you buy and sell stocks
ETFs options and Kryptos all commission
free with Robin Hood you can learn how
to invest in the market as you build
your portfolio you discover new stocks
you trade your favorite companies and
you get custom notifications for price
movement so you never miss the right
movement to invest now again Robin Hood
is given the church family free stock
like Apple Ford or sprint to help you
build your portfolio again Robin Hood is
giving our listeners the Church of
what's happened now a free stock like
Apple for the sprint to help build your
portfolio what I want you to do is sign
in at church dot Robin Hood com let's
get this party started
was that the roller skating rink where
you and your let's go baby
does you're a roller skate yeah hot
skates Limburg Long Island oh [ __ ]
yep yep nice the way of spandex pants
though you how old feathers coming out
of my hair how old were you
my father was like what the [ __ ] I was
like 17 I could I couldn't roller skate
for [ __ ] both the [ __ ] yeah they had
a girlfriend at 13 14 you had a roller
so no no young i only roller skating
like three times and that was it for me
was like uh like uh she was a chick that
wanna go on Sunday so I went with a
couple day if you could go backwards man
that was the ticket I can go backwards
we used to whole line backwards in front
woods ah push up but I still remember
the most I saw a guy fall off I saw a
guy fall his wig fall off people they
were definitely you you were one of
those people right I was sitting on the
side minding my own business
yeah talking to like three guys like the
way we are just looking at the girls
roll escape mm-hmm and also this guy was
dancing his [ __ ] and I couldn't even
tell he had a rug out you got a rug on
and awesome he went down and the rug
came off and somebody rolled his kids
over the rug and he tried to grab it
[Laughter]
with the tape it was on backwards so the
sideburns would come down you look like
[ __ ] no no is this New Jersey that'll
be like the part we were kids we used to
roller skate I like to say it was
Paramus I'd like to tell you was Paramus
but I don't know what the [ __ ] it was I
was like I said it was the sixth grade
yeah
seventh grade this place hot skates is
still there in Long Island actually did
a Kevin can wait an episode with Kevin
James ironically a year ago and I did a
scene I was running a hot skate rink
when Leah Remini at hot skates I could
not freaking believe it besides I was
just chasing yeah yeah whatever but I
mean it was funny I'm like I [ __ ]
used to go here with my girlfriend I
grew up here at hot skates and Here I am
filming a scene 30 years later you know
what Kevin and Leigh I was like I'm like
weird um I had this unbelievable right
near Rockville Center
when I went to high school st. Agnes
Cathedral is my old stomping grounds may
Merrick Boulevard it was Mara Boulevard
Sunrise Highway Long Island Lynn Brook
Valley Stream Rockville Center I lived
in Rosedale which was like right on the
borderline of Queens and then Long
Island started Nassau County [ __ ]
weird man couldn't believe it believe I
forgot about roller skating till I saw
Brenner and she did a bit about it and
they took me back like I was in the
original room and he was started
like oh [ __ ] I forgot about that I won't
roll a scan the guy with the wig it's
cool buddy there's something cool about
it it's almost like the drive-in movie
theater like Majan bringing that [ __ ]
back imagine somebody bringing the
drive-in you remember to drive him when
we did was [ __ ] while you put the
radio in the window the whole family
were going to station wagon and hide
under a blanket it's [ __ ] great you
know some of those things that was so
you don't realize how special they were
towing you look back and go wow
all this gate what movies did you see
the driver that's terrible our warriors
yeah warriors I saw Five Fingers a debt
root three and Clifton Wow somebody
recently maybe about nine months ago on
Facebook said Joey you ain't [ __ ] unless
you remember this and it brought like
sent me a funny message and said tell me
what you know about this is something
like it like what do you know about this
[ __ ] man and I was like dawg I saw five
fingers at death I felt probably for top
notch movies there that I cannot
remember because there had to be some
with shooting people mm-hmm cuz my
stepfather would take me then we put the
Box in the window then after 45 minutes
Villa turn the car on because the
windows would get fogged up right so 45
minutes share to turn the car around I
still remember that thing you haven't
even remembering a memory of how much
the drive-in movie did it was like I'm
just too little so I don't remember like
I couldn't have been a lot right but
they charge you by the head it charge
about like a lot of times they still
like hide us under the blanket I said
would you put us in the trunk yeah they
put us in the trunk or some [ __ ] I'll
tell you what else I thought the
drive-in movie grease grease grease I
saw at that drive-in movie because
that's the one we snuck a bunch of
Puerto Ricans in the trunk in fact I was
one of them we wanted three in it was
like four four five hours is actually a
scene in Lords of Flatbush which is a
really good underrated movie that's the
lone day with Perry King oh my god is
this Seema Perry King he's trying to get
with Susan Blakely at the sunrise
drive-in where we went as kids and
Valley Stream is that dry
in theater you watch that movie and you
see his trainees getting on hot pants
and she likes she's is up in the lords
of flat was good movie war [ __ ]
Rockies before rocky Sauron in the movie
I saw that in the movie theater and I
didn't know I had American Graffiti that
I'm coming at the same time is an under
our underrated right nobody nobody glad
he stuck out Stallone see ya the diamond
scene when he goes yeah when he goes in
there I thought the guy right yeah but
you made a mistake right you know what I
mean right
then he goes out signing that did I do
it did I do it you know right pops the
movie on that of why the Lords of
Flatbush yeah in 79 I don't know I'm the
kids a that remember the line in the
movie was leave no no no that's not a
rip was leaving a movie I know I leave
the kid alone that's a good move what
was available - I'll tell you in a
second I'm my guy no it's a great movie
what the [ __ ] what is wrong with my
memory I say more about Lords of
Flatbush and Adam loved that and he
loved this movie - the one we're talking
I leave the kid alone - Porky's boy no
not Porky's it was a book and it's a
good movies all about those gangs in New
York yes the Chinese gang a tiny gang of
black gang I had a buddy who was a
nitwit The Wanderers the wander is yeah
I'm the kind of guy yeah yeah it was a
[ __ ] good movie has a great and the
guy who made the film I I met in my
audition from I figured his name is good
filmmaker Oh Kaufman
I believe Phil Kaufman and that's a good
Morris ken wall man he was good in wall
he was a leading man he was a wise guy
here and a bigot a guy leave the kid
alone
yeah wall I think Ken wall was great in
Fort Apache the Bronx he was young Paul
no one know man they need a yellow the
mexican chick from man on fire yeah
never change
she was the hot nurse at the [ __ ] it's a
good movie party but you haven't seen
for the patchy the Bronx see these
movies The Wanderers Lords of Flatbush
oh my god I just remembered a whole
different genre yeah of movies he's all
good water passionate Bronx with Miguel
paneros the galloping
it was a movie called short-eyes you
ever see that what I thought eyes Miguel
piñero dinero wrote that I think yes it
was a prison and then they did a play
about with your male role playing Ralph
Macchio that was the guy rape Avadh who
wrote that yes and then he died of HIV
HIV and he was a journalist John did a
play called la puta vida right and the
gin ski choked it was a Spanish place
and I saw John Leguizamo make his debut
and De Niro did the other play Kuber and
his teddy bear we're out of Montreal
right and I met that guy ray provided
and he was a he was an interesting
Puerto Rican guy from the Lower East
Side I think you know and I'm great
writer great writer and he died you know
I'm very young but man I mean the guy
could write there was a guy Michael
carmine who could act his ass off he
also died he was in that group I saw him
come onstage and do a monologue my
[ __ ] shoes were blown off my feet
blown off my I said that my brother who
is this guy who is that the Public
Theater because John was great and then
the Coen brothers saw that and they got
inspired that's why I wrote that guy in
the the what he called the love was that
[ __ ] movie he plays the Jesus in that
movie The Big Lebowski The Big Lebowski
yeah so that play that he plays that
Puerto Rican pedophile guy it was based
on a character he did and Ray provides
play that's what their that's where they
got the idea of that character the Jesus
that my brother did in The Big Lebowski
in The Big Lebowski that's right so you
go back short-eyes and then that was
Miguel piñero and then Ray provide wrote
these plays that there that's the one
play De Niro did he never did much many
plays then I saw John dude he's plays at
the public and that was Ray provide and
this other guy Michael come on great
actor man great actor man we can open
air pretty much wrote Miami Vice I think
a lot to do I mean there were there are
guys that don't get the credit no you
know I I just didn't have the ideas
right what's his name yeah I know
even would have been a friend of mine
who had a lot to do it you know Chad's
Parmenter you know he basically like
wrote Mike Starr bow saw you know these
guys in this guy Frank Renzulli great
writer kind of like helped him write or
develop like you know there wasn't they
were outraged when he got a deal and all
this [ __ ] but they were they helped Chaz
and all this [ __ ] and you know Chaz
knocked them out or whatever you know
there's always stories like that where
guys didn't get there you know they had
a lot to do with it but they wanted to
leave guy and then they got shunned you
know so probably he was like that kind
of guy I remember watching it was a
double feature I think it was short eyes
and something else it might have been a
Scorsese movie and I just remember
seeing that was a long time you saw that
right what's that short eyes a law yeah
probably hard to find they did a play
yep that was a play also probably well
he got it appraised he was a playwright
- right yeah that's like like like this
other guy rape Avadh they're gonna movie
about Miguel piñero it's what was that
cause who played him are that Benjamin
Benjamin Bratt nice guy tried to how did
he do listen is he deep enough to play
him I don't know man tried yes no yeah
unless you really knew him and knew that
keys were like hardcore porterie these
guys seventies that with junkies right
junkie and they financed their junk true
doing what the Fourth Ward I was like
yeah I would put together a small
theater right put plays and then there
that's ranked problems and they would
set up these [ __ ] things I always had
that like three of them were junk stirs
mmm-hmm but one of them would always at
least show right but they always had to
go hunt the other one down you know with
New York in the 70s that junk destroyed
I saw that jerk the guy that turned me
on to Richard Pryor wasn't Porter Rico
junkie right
his younger brother took me to his house
[ __ ] bro my brothers would come out of
the room don't be scared then what he
talking about I thought he was like a
monster or south he was sick listen to
the Beals I'm gonna forget that never
get that day it's like in my head like
because they were so hardcore right
hardcore yeah
heroin took those poor Porto Rican kids
in the Bronco when I was a kid and my
mother had the drycleaner I would see
people Noddin everywhere New York City
was an odd capital of the country you're
saying what's nodding when people are
falling asleep right and [ __ ] funny
it Wow
and it would fall asleep on the streets
you know that scene went when American
gangster women driving down the street
they show those zombies right I still
remember that that little window in New
York yeah there was a little window and
everybody want on methadone they got
worse for a while but dear this is uh 73
to 77 when those guys were running
things they were really and they were
brilliant I provide Miguel piñero they
all had that a genius in them that GDL
it's like huh what's that movie bullets
over Broadway which has momentary yeah
he was brilliant than that was grating
cuz he was a gangster right but yet he
wasn't and he was a poet yeah he helped
write the mm-hmm he was given the
inspiration for it and you can't see it
guy that's been a writer all his life
right and guys like this crazy are doing
the same type of job because they have a
voice and they lived it and if you could
get that voice on the page you know
that's that's like you can't you know
you can't write that stuff you can't
find people even right as camera because
they didn't they didn't experience it
you know so if you can bring that to the
to the page forget it you know I mean
it's just like your [ __ ] you do hear and
your humor if you try to get it on the
page for a show you gotta get that's why
you gotta be involved in it to get your
voice there unless there's a guy that
and these guys are gone there's nobody
around like that anymore
that in New York you're talking about I
was watching this thing recently on
Jimmy Breslin and Pete Hamill about New
York and in New York papers and it was
fantastic
when we grew up the news the post Jimmy
Breslin was a start he says what stars
of a journalist but they worked their
way up from copy boy they were [ __ ]
didn't go to didn't even graduate high
school you know and they became
superstars but there was just
reporters but they had a voice stand a
voice and they were real they would
report but they would also they would
tell stories New York stories the paper
the New York Daily News the New York
Post it was it was great to get the pay
now that business is gone it's going
should watch this documentary I have a
piece of to have a together Daily News
and to have it on the arm what I
wouldn't accorded role I did role with a
[ __ ] and a coffee with a coffee I went
in those days I was a coconut can you
understand what that is or you I know
we've talked about that but that's
genius
that was beautiful that was the top of
your day Lee you know you have you ever
had a butter roll in New York I don't
think so okay
one day when you go to New York open
your eyes you gotta I'm only kidding but
you gotta [ __ ] have a butterball
right you gotta go to like a Mabel ya
neighborhood deli that's Dalian be fresh
roll roll be fresh was in New York he
knows a different and [ __ ] you you
can't get a butter roll out here no
[ __ ] way you could get a butter roll
out here okay I'm so sorry no it's not
your fault I'm not mad at you you know
it's a different it was a different plan
with you to have a newspaper only arm to
get on the subway and have the 30
minutes to [ __ ] read the New York
Post or a story about somebody who got
arrest in the Bronx you know and then
you look at what number came out and
then you'd read the [ __ ] sports
section but I always knew I was always
Daily News guy because they gave me
chill numbers me till post made their
own life yeah so that's why I never
there's always a little more cheesy
yeah post was cheesy I wasn't daily news
time no she's got like you see it now
everybody got fired it's like 10 pages
it's there's nobody there so it's it's a
shame they won 250 for it at the airport
I shoplifted Oh every time I go back
someone I blame you I take right to do
the same thing they have to New York
Daily News right there by a thing they
want 450 for it I know I pick it up man
I know I pick it up fold it up
under my arm and pay for the water like
where'd you get the pay you justify you
coming at the house the other day I was
shopping with my wife and she tried to
bust me for drinking something I said
I just spent $70 at CVS what do you want
to [ __ ] bust me my own wife and she's
like we didn't pay for that so what I
spent money there
I spent [ __ ] money so I figure I can
justify drinking a [ __ ] drink as well
I'm walking around alone I still
remember a movie with Joe Namath we made
a sandwich I never did that I never made
a sandwich I had a friend she she's
something I wasn't easy rider' the big
guy that's right I spot bro
he made a sandwich in a movie fat guy
after that would walk into a supermarket
rip open Oscar Mayer cold cuts you know
and get a fresh thing of bread yeah that
was your goal in the mid 70s rank was to
make a sandwich in a supermarket man you
never did it I was too scared now it was
worth this shoplift I could shoplift
yeah I can shop with like a mother I'm
good at Spanish train talk about I'm
East Harlem train I'm better at it I'm
really good at shopping yeah but that
[ __ ] of making a sandwich petrified this
[ __ ] up yeah I would put a pack of our
ten pack of gum down my pants a shop
right if you think you're touching my
dick if you think I'm gonna Michael
Jackson's nephew you better step back I
will [ __ ] you up this ain't never
Neverland [ __ ] on me I swear to God I
Scott stop so many times and they would
say we have to search you well that was
12 but young and I would tell him first
off you don't warm with say that yeah
she would say you know what you're like
they were 12 because the guy that was
whit was a cop oh so he wasn't really
again so I go before you [ __ ] Paul
you know where him went he was known for
throwing Beatles Carmine this cop was
calm beans and I hung out with his shop
right shop we just talked anybody into
we could talk you into anything because
we knew this guy so why do you only go
for gum we would do any of my mean
time we were just shoplifting Gumley we
had the money to go he we would eat a
normal sandwich on the way back from
Union City right we'd stop in the shop
right and each of us would take a ten
pack a ten pack hubba bubba and then we
go back to school chew it and then
whipping at one another make [ __ ]
chunks I mean we were Hannibal in the
seventh I did three years at that school
three years in the seventh grade and
when you're in the eighth grade you stab
me and those three years I cuz after I
got thrown out of Catholic school I went
there and those three years were [ __ ]
tremendous even though I got left back
that was a half of all I thought what
the butter roll you dip dip it in the
coffee you know that Spanish [ __ ] in
Spanish [ __ ] Cubans like it's Cuban like
that Cuban take the bread and bother
them in the coffee
did you know you not much yes you did
I try yes you did people do it I don't
like I don't like it that much that's
one thing that always kill I didn't like
coffee as a kid
me neither now I love ever drank it
flowers can't function without it didn't
start drinking coffee till 2000 I made
me shake it is that tea with lemon I was
a real wimp I couldn't drink why make
gaming shakes my dad used to have sank
going on so when I was a kid I drank all
those Cuban expressos and they twist me
up
really when I was a kid I would go to
Hernandez and [ __ ] get two of those
yeah what do you drink now whatever my
table that's gonna Frey the Machine his
cafe whatever the [ __ ] yeah what do you
have a couple of day in the morning you
have a cup of coffee and good morning
wanted so and then like got an 8 o'clock
this is my secret you get a burl oh yeah
but what I do is but if I have to do
comedy right about 8:30 I blast a
four-day expresso oh really
I'll make 4 Express Oh before you do
comedy and 8:30 let's say my spots at
10:15 man I'm ready to bust
yeah I smoke some reefer yeah I sprinkle
some [ __ ] my Luca juice on it and I
don't listen to the radio on the way to
the store yeah oh really get me wired
and sound I got my [ __ ] grip so hard
as I'm going down Laurel Canyon huh
that's how you pump yourself up
[ __ ] yeah and I do okay well
I need a baguette thing Sunday night at
the Comedy Store but I think sadly
Thursday Thursday
you got either bag of dicks from time to
time it's showing you you're growing
yeah yeah people don't realize that like
when I left there I called Liam my car
the biggest bag of dicks and Philly
being a year and a half comic he said oh
my god you know I don't make Doug yeah
he was like happy about it he always
happy because you get it out of the way
yeah that means you're not got a bomb
for a while no if I bomb again next week
right then [ __ ] I got at least a bomb oh
yeah yeah you still bomber yeah this
last Sunday I know exactly what I did
yeah it's rule but only on for how long
this week 20 minutes 20 minutes yeah
this Sunday and I want to bomb you're
talking about yeah 27 I did 40 40 or an
hour he bombed no I did well then well
my time right I went to the setups
Sunday I went down there and I sure I
wasn't supposed to be on it wasn't my
hobby store oh it wasn't my type of show
right and was the audience wrong the
audience is right it was everything I
did was wrong I went out there maybe a
little too cocky and then I went out
there without setting them up you gotta
put a finger up their ass first you
gotta size their back you gotta rub
their titties you can't punch him with a
[ __ ] right off the top of the sundae I
forgot it was Sunday really creates a
different mind right that's different
energy
what Sunday's are very different
energies I never liked yeah I realized
as I was going up the hill and I got off
the phone with Lee I go it's a cop-out
right but for me it's a reality 27 years
I mean don't tell me for that long I've
never liked doing communist I know I
don't like it so they don't like it when
you say bond I mean like wow the
audience just didn't you know didn't
take the full ride they didn't take the
ride you know it right
I mean I knew from the second joke that
this might not be a guy and I wasn't
they ran for me and did you did you and
then i agitated them with racial jokes
oh you did see if I'm gonna need my wife
so I UD out and all that [ __ ] didn't
really push them because I know I don't
have you right so I'm a little Pricer
you get angry you didn't know I didn't
get it I don't get angry talk about
eating [ __ ] and all that yeah
flipping on them a little bit I get
dirty it yeah your finger up there
something right okay no now they really
tightened up on me
yeah I know I tried to pull it out at
that point now at the 10-minute listen
you get in your head everybody bombs you
have to bomb baby some bomb is an act to
some time some days just all savages
yeah this is why you have you only
bombed five or ten percent at a time
that's good right this is why the
Yankees were always so good although she
is because out of nine guys all I need a
three to be hit the ball right every
World Series we won the World Series but
yeah but this guy went off for 17 look
at what he did June July and August man
he got into the World Series by August
he peeled out a little bit
he ain't always 3432 but look who came
through that white guy that nobody
talked about Julian you hated him in
June right you hated him he struck out
in the ninth inning he left men on base
but look look who went 8 for 9 the world
8 out of 12 in the World Series if you
don't correct me right if history
corrects me because we were talking
about all the World Championships the
Red Sox one of the war uh when the Red
Sox played the Cincinnati Reds 75 and 75
yeah you know bailed them out the guy
that had gotten over 17 Tony Perez
Tony Perez went over 18 he hit the
single that killed the Red Sox I don't
know I don't remember and look what he
was a great hit
he was a great hitter Tony Perez but if
you look at him the World Series
Cincinnati did the same thing Cincinnati
played what's that movie Brad Pitt made
our money more money boy they played
Moneyball what in that World Series it
and the way this style Cincinnati Reds
style way to irritate you the Big Red
Machine a Big Red Machine style was if
you watch a game now the data class a
channel a couple years ago called
classic and OB right I know if it's
still on and I'm in the way two times I
was away on the road and I got stuck
watching the games yeah and I was
mesmerised I was I didn't remember that
strategy I didn't know strategies when I
was 10
their strategy was who was then leadoff
hitter
Joe Morgan John Morgan and what did he
always do but it's a little bit yeah and
if he got out first that was your end
that was it
you know what his percentages were I'm
getting out first six out of ten so once
he got out first what what else was his
job Morgan loan to do I am still basis
there you go so now we start torturing
the pitcher yeah but he was a complete
plain now we start swinging from the
side remember he would swing his
shoulders like he was gonna [ __ ] tree
I can see why you really connected with
this day then active number two was like
heroes heroes yeah that's a single
that's that's a guy on first that's
gonna steal second so you're already
hitting the [ __ ] glove with the ball
Wow and now bu now you gotta face Pete
Rose it's [ __ ] 7:35 its 7:35 in most
[ __ ] places and I gotta throw up Pete
Rose with your Morgan over here
and he's gonna steal he's gonna steal a
[ __ ] base and then he'd steal Morgan
pushed him to throw and then Rose would
get a bad thing number three Johnny
Bench you can't get out of this rotation
and they had like four teams they had
four teams that would just torment you i
watch the game where the whole rotation
went twice Don Gullett hit like a single
yeah like even down go with the big
singles
he's stealing bases like I remember one
time when I watch them on that classic
thing when they took the picture out you
could tell the pitcher telling the coach
like I'm done mm-hmm I'm done I'm going
back to the farm I don't need this David
[ __ ] do home runs they stole 18 bases
on one inning oh yeah they would steal
all play just to [ __ ] with your burn
aggressive they were very aggressive
concepción wooden exceptions are the
kids father
you had ken griffey generally senior
yeah and Eric foster who was George
Foster who was the only guy on the team
was I bet say Geronimo say Geronimo this
was a team that was the team and it was
solid year but they drove you crazy they
were a great team they were great they
do feel a banging on the door 70
to 7d they were banging in the playoff
70 treated then they lost to the meds
and then the Oakland A's what you made
they lost in 72 nobody else
yes that first sound bad go abandon I
was their first World Series a good team
too is a good team Gene Tenace
with the [ __ ] go Rudy they look like
though they look like the Village People
they all had moustaches they're by the
blue they had [ __ ] Reggie Jackson
whatever campaneras they were [ __ ]
great team bill north they were dick
green they were [ __ ] great team the
Oakland A's they were the swing and A's
they actually won in 72 73 and 74 and
then the Reds the Big Red Machine came
of age 75 and 76 they swept the Yankees
in 76 Big Red Machine like embarrass the
Yankees they here the Yankees won the
pennant then won a pennant in 12 years
Chris Chambliss hit a home run but they
swept the Yankees out and they're good
this year before 75 that's when they
beat the Reds and that red sock in that
great seven-game epic series whose great
game 6 was the great game where they
[ __ ] gate tied the game Bernie carbo
tied the game was an X read and he
looking he was getting overmatched he
hits a three run home and tie it and
then Carlton Fisk a [ __ ] beloved red
sock you know he was great play this man
hit one off the foul pole and then Game
seven they were winning like three
nothing Red Sox and then they came back
Perez hit a home run I think all [ __ ]
Billy McHugh yeah and a little single I
think they won 43 how do you I remember
[ __ ] about baseball amazing that I could
not remember anything about my whole
life but if you ask me [ __ ] you can I
can put myself right there in this and
right in the place watching the game
watching the pitch
I know exact where I exact facts of
baseball to the tee especially in the
70s and I can't remember [ __ ] about my
life but I could tell you who true to
pitch you know you know it's
unbelievable
I'm buddy how it sticks in my [ __ ]
head especially in the 70s it's so
engrained
I was watching that Bucky Dent at-bat
against Mike Torrez it's just fantastic
in 78 when he hit the home run but he
fouled the ball off he cracked his bat
Mickey rivers gives him a back he goes
hey homey hey home
your bat is cracked your bat is cracked
didn't [ __ ] Bucky Dent didn't know
and then they took a long time before
they went and my Torres never threw a
[ __ ] warm-up pitch he never threw a
warm-up pitch and then after the kid
that gave him the bat he was from my
town Rosedale sir Andrea handed the
[ __ ] town
handed the back to [ __ ] Bucky Dent
and Bucky Dent hit the three run home I
was in my friend's basement Yankees were
up three to say when I went up four to
five to Reggie hit a home on Red Sox
came back five four and the ninth inning
they had [ __ ] first and third and two
outs where the goose thrown the [ __ ]
the eyes and the eyes popped it up yeah
has popped up the mother [ __ ] watch
the Mets growing up yeah I watch boys
Theodore George Theodore all and Tom
Seaver Koosman Grodi up all of them
because I'm from Queens oh I knew the
Mets first and some kids took me my had
a Puerto Rican friend he took me to the
Bronx I was [ __ ] in my boots I never
went to the Bronx 73 that's how I went
that's how I became a Yankee fan
my friend Julius Pacheco who's the
[ __ ] Puerto Rican kid took me to the
Yankee Stadium and I fell in love man I
fell in love with Bobby Mercer and
Thurman once I was like wow people were
like how the [ __ ] were you a Yankee fan
you're [ __ ] from Queens you from
Rosedale the Mets I know that's all I
knew was the Mets when I was a kid you
know and then I the Yankees weren't very
good then but the Mets were really
probably more loaded they're probably
more loved than the Yankees because you
got to remember New York was in National
League City you know that you had two
teams he three teams back in a day the
Giants the Dodgers those were national
league teams the Yankees were always
[ __ ] hated the Dodgers were loved
there were more loved then the Mets are
basically like a [ __ ] bastard child of
the Giants and the Dodgers like those
[ __ ] teams had an affair in a left
town and then the [ __ ] Mets were born
if you look at the Mets colors there all
the [ __ ] Dodger and giant colors the
blue the orange in this song is
hilarious meet the Mets
meet the Med step right up and greet the
bad bad I thought it cracks me up
you know Shea Stadium I remember had
friends that would well I had friends
that would bet the Mets and the game
would start you was saying beat the Mets
yeah come on down [ __ ] you beat them
well I'm at fan cuz you remember George
do all the flowers a [ __ ] die heart
she was a met fan and a Red Sox fan but
the love our life was Tom see Tom Seaver
in my book maybe one of the greatest
pictures of Seaver was the Lala she was
in love with him uh-huh she wasn't mad
then when they traded to Cincinnati
Dallas she was popular heartbroken she
humiliated rusty Staub aah
she humiliated Agron it made us they
made her sit on the other side I'm right
field he was a right field right yeah
number four anything made this they
stopped a left field because she would
throw chicken wings not really rusty I
dressed why she lastly because he
dropped the ball one night she lost a
bet
god forbid so she never let rusty die
like she [ __ ] tormenting me he was
alive she would've gone for the cemetery
his fellows gray she would give you like
the name of eight plays that she bumped
into she was gonna smack him in the face
she carried like a list and she knew
exactly why they made me lose a thousand
bucks or whatever she stole a bell from
my church once and in the last year one
of the reasons why I got thrown out of
Catholic school I was great for two and
a half years in a Catholic school
Catholic school I was a firm Catholic
what was any Catholic school Sacred
Heart School for Boys besides it was a
Grammar School up grammar school in
eighth grade but it was uh what do you
call that when you sleep there Oh
morning school make the [ __ ] it's funny
a couple nights ago I remember the story
I remember you know people always know
how to [ __ ] do you remember these
stories because I remember one and as
I'm writing one right I remember another
right because one one trig is another I
have questions that yeah yeah how come
at this place there was really no sexual
molestation like I thought back I mean
there was but maybe you know you know
what a couple nights ago I took the one
night that I talked to Leah had a double
expresso like 9 o'clock and I was off
the [ __ ] rails and like four
expressos me any like night
clock and I got home from the comedy
store was more wide when I got home and
I went online I found the thread for a
reddit reddit uh-huh that cool yeah
ready and there was people that had gone
there before me the same good high
school and Sacred Heart at school it was
like a page for people from like I was
there from 70 to 73 and this was a page
for people who had been there from 1962
to 66 it was an orphanage uh-huh
and then it opened up as a school in New
Jersey they shot The Sopranos on Kearny
New Jersey in Kearny New Jersey it was
right up the street
well I shot Annalise that we shot at two
blocks in there I even asked the store
West Wilson Avenue because the school
was 122 Wilson and he goes Wilson Avenue
two blocks now I thought and that's why
I remembered this road I remembered that
they would pick me up shoot up and this
is the road to route right whatever 46
of yeah we don't wanna bring ones over
there no that's that's towards uh
towards the Fort George Washington
Bridge okay this isn't this is 15 20
minutes away
suburbia it's a street I think the sorry
Alice was there and or maybe not I could
be wrong I know for sure the hardware
store with Chris Moltisanti his
father-in-law right one day used was I
think around that could be bang on
amateur but I went on the reddit page
and most of complaints I found 90% of
them were the beatings that the kids
took all beatings yeah cuz they would
beat you there right and then one kid
didn't mention and a nun that was there
when I was there sister Regina and the
one that hit me sister Isis were
mentioned in that threat and everybody
had the same thing to say about sister
Iceland I hope she's burning in hell
yeah she [ __ ] helped me in the eye
one time you know ba ba ba ba ba I had
done great at that school great I didn't
like me because I didn't drink milk oh I
didn't like milk
I may be nice to it I don't like milk I
don't like it so they would pour it over
my head no yeah you know at the end you
know show me tre
milk all your little jails walking you
know uh TV dinner portion right had to
be empty and then they would check your
milk in your water you gotta drink your
milk and your glass of water and I would
always drink the water
yeah believe I can only I would have to
drink milk the weight only way he leads
mushroom as his stuff hold your mouth
yeah nose I mean that's how bad I
[ __ ] hate it did you drink chocolate
milk like a [ __ ] yeah strawberry
milk and strawberry Quik yeah did it
except that well you have to drink back
in those days they believed you no no he
said you needed milk Leah bones or some
[ __ ] she [ __ ] drew beans on me and
then like the last year that the last
year so I got a little old I was hanging
on it for the a shoot some [ __ ] you
know where I lived was nice white kids
mmm my god mullets they were Street kids
right and their rules were a lot
different from the rules on any a
straight their rule these kids lived for
to a bedroom you know their rules are
different right and I started listening
to their rules a little more their rules
made a little bit more sense to me
mm-hmm I would tell them they would you
get hit you know everybody in the
seventies knew that right
but that was no is no there was no yeah
you got hit and they would say the next
time they hear you block that [ __ ] and
they would tell me stories about that
cousin your mom knocked out another in
the Bronx and I'd be like why really
you're gonna [ __ ] done yet Wow they
[ __ ] punched her and [ __ ] on my pal
that yeah but you're gonna go to hell
for that yeah as far as like thinking
about them like I started thinking like
house I was going there Ruth we came out
you know what I remember one beat but I
got that wasn't Pleasant and I remember
going home not saying none of my mother
and just saying to my son the next time
you know I didn't talk to that nun like
I never had contact and a paddle I got a
paddle - they had a paddle point yeah
yeah well they would that you would have
point it then there was a guy there that
had been in the orphanage and he would
have a dog that would bite you really
like a little mud dog that would grab
your jeans and [ __ ] and he would eat you
with the stick if you think about it now
then as a child you don't know you know
it's amazing they got away with that
[ __ ] away with it
in the seventies if you went home and
told your father that the gun on the
Block Lee kicked you yeah you go what he
kicked you for there's got to be a
reason why I call them a [ __ ] Jew
okay there you go
well then I'm a cue because I didn't
raise you to call people [ __ ] exactly
so you couldn't go home with no hay they
wouldn't back you all back back you up
man you deserve it's rang up and stuff
you [ __ ] up they'd say well there's a
reason why you must believe not like
today the parents would come to the kids
defense or whatever you know the kid did
wrong he would you know haul you know
you can't touch my kid no matter what he
does but back then they you know they
could do that they could do that yeah
but that I went back on the threat and
there was nothing for sexual assault but
I remember they told me I told the story
on stage I don't know if I told what
stage I remembered about the kid I stuck
up for when I got thrown on the campus
there was a reason why I stuck up for
him the reason why I stuck up for that
kid was he was a little on the weak side
and his brother with twins and they've
the one the guy I stuck up for was
getting harassed by this big black kid
mm-hmm this big black kid's name was
lazarino he could have been Cuban or for
the reef in the Dominican I don't know
we just say he was a black kid right
because he was very very dark I remember
being very very dark right and there
were rumors going around allows arena
was [ __ ] people in the ass really I'm
the playground that la Cerrito would
always ask people yeah we could do it
all the time and show like that but I
guess he found the weakness in Rafael
mm-hmm and the Bravo brothers and he
started like [ __ ] I'll never forget
that I was a couple beds from them but
their beds their heads were together oh
boy so he would hear more come on I come
on that's called the bathroom we can get
away with it and you people said they
could hear it and I was like hey you
[ __ ] guys crazy
no I've never earned that that I was ten
I didn't know anything about that world
yeah I knew about gay men right but I
didn't know that guys did it when they
were in the fifth [ __ ] grade I had no
[ __ ] idea of this yeah that's like it
sure enough one that I'd have to pee
like three in the morning like I got up
and the nuns boom
you know you would sleep in a big
dormitory and then none slept in the
dormitory with you her room had a door
and a war but the ceiling was open like
there'd be so she could hear us do you
know who said yeah and I'm gonna forget
that I don't know if I woke up to pee or
I don't know if I woke up from hearing
lies arena or [ __ ] that kid and I'll
never forget like getting up put my
slippers on and walking towards the
bathroom really see it between you and
me man do you know for a fact that you
saw between you between you and I I sort
of something you saw something I saw
something oh my sounds like Ted what it
was I don't know Oh what it was I don't
know what they I didn't know what that
the sex positions were I was 10 years
old yeah and it's not what I saw them
over the urinals oh boy oh okay and he
was doing something to his ass I don't
know what he was doing so I went back to
way down
[Laughter]
what are you doing corrupt them no rape
of the Missoula's do it all and I'll
never forget that I'd talk to like you
know there was there was a couple kids
from the Union City right you want
traumatized but you didn't really see
there was a couple hits from Union City
that I had grown up with later after
that there was a kid that his father had
a pharmacy six blocks in my mother's bar
and there was another kid that had grown
up them there was a smurfier family
there were to Allah they had put there
were two brothers through barrows and I
bumped into them years later yeah and
whenever I would beg them they would
always go hey you remember last arena
will be [ __ ] Rafael Bravo and I always
felt really bad about that like I always
felt like man that and this year I did a
show at Gotham and one of the guys
Shelly married one of my friends they
got married later on in life like in
their forties one of the guys in the
boarding school
the boarding school and I started
talking going back and forth night tango
is do you take class because I never
mumbling is about that it goes to Rafael
KITT was a kind of finook to I don't
know if you remember that I I mistook it
as a week right they act kind of like
you know I don't remember who knows it
that is what the other night in my
[ __ ] highness yeah there's not only
am I [ __ ] whacking that I know in my
eye on the caffeine yeah I'm also
whacking that dude salutes back every 15
minutes I met there with the pipe I'm
listening to music I'm writing in a
notebook I got a computer open at the
same time let me check on this I
remember and I checked that on Nazarene
I went through all the Facebook and
there he was nothing a grown man that
went to I went to his messages I tried
to be his friend add me what'd he say
yeah I didn't hear nothing and then I
hit him with a message 8u my [ __ ]
Rafi Oh Bravo in the ass and the next
day he was off Facebook Oh again so dud
so I was right so you were wrong I was
right I was right something had happened
oh yeah but it's now you know fact that
you said you know yeah and he might have
been too fruity tamati banging - kidding
me and whatever the cool oh yeah and I
felt really bad because wow I remembered
those kids how bad like the kid was
traumatized after you got five years
dramatized that's not like a bunch of
kids jerking off and they get caught by
their parents or something yeah I mean
that's that's a little worse that's
pretty bad we had a shower Wow like I'm
in The Sopranos and the kid was taking
the shiny [ __ ] in the shower remember
that episode yeah yeah a bunch in the
school shower I'll never forget that we
used to stand around the shower one day
Liza read over log on a piece of soap
and put up all the kids asses and she
was on the sole he threw it on the floor
oh my god look at the bug table who the
[ __ ] would put this she thought I did it
they type of guy that put some bars so
I'd like she was smacking people who did
that with a bar of soap
oh and La Serena what behind some kid
anyone like that yes is dirty and the
soap was white with a little I look like
a [ __ ] no cold but the other one
that's dipped in chocolate Oh God oh my
god I should be saying this [ __ ] I know
crazy because I was watching that
[ __ ] Michael Jackson thing I don't
want you it was a bad yeah bed it's now
who is it coming from who some of these
kids that two kids that went to testify
that Michael was good to him and then
the effects of this stuff came into
their lives you know the effects of
getting your tongue licked at seven and
you know then the kid came back to shoot
the video and it was Macaulay Culkin and
I related to one part of it I did relate
to one part of it because it happened to
me he's being overwhelmed all the
parents were very overwhelmed so they're
not talking to Nick totora who lives in
whatever [ __ ] you live there talking to
make the tour who lives
Rosedale right and you fall the work
hard everything your mother worked hard
and all of a sudden you do a dance
contest and you win they take a picture
of Michael Jackson request to me and he
flies to your hometown they made she
meets your parents and also in a week
later he flies you and your middle-class
working parents out from Queens
right I mean they both did similar
stories you know you go to you know
these kids were saying that's [ __ ] that
it was Michael Jackson so you went to
Toys
and it was like fill the car to the top
but on top of that they're taking care
your parents you know so now Michael
Jackson comes to you and says I [ __ ]
love Nick Nick you know right how old
he's seven weeks it'll be a great
[ __ ] dancer the talent is overbearing
I wanna take you and them on the road on
my international tour right Japan Tokyo
Australia all the places you your
parents ever dreamed about going they
like two nickels to rub together mm-hmm
and guess what at the beginning of the
tour you're staying right next to
Michael Jackson's room to suite and you
got a maid and groom service but the
other night your kid wants to sleep with
Michael see you like you don't want to
break your kids are sure he's with his
hero how harmless could this be all
right and then you know just told these
stories that and I look at it as getting
overwhelmed you know you're middle class
I mean the one lady even said he lent
this money to buy a house and Simi
Valley Mike was very generous and whole
thing
there's a story these two guys and I um
this I had this happen to somebody close
to me right the similar situation didn't
happen with a celebrity it happened to
them with a relative right and they you
know pulled me aside when they sit and
they talk to me and this person says
y'all kids here are these similar
stories similar stories of what how they
were rotated how you know what he did
what he didn't do how he kept in touch
with them how the kid and both of them
are successful like they both went out
one kid went to be a call choreographer
uh-huh Britney Spears and well he was 14
he tried to [ __ ] him in the ass and then
it hurt too much so he [ __ ] took his
dick out yeah and he drove into this
house the car drove into his house and
he went back to what happened the mother
then the next day Michael secretary
called that they were gonna pick him up
right away and Michael brother to the
studio and said would you do at the end
the way he goes go home and get it
before anybody finds it because there
might be blood stains in it you know
it's just
there I don't know what you said there
as a parent you said there is a human
being you said there is a man
you said there is somebody who likes
kids but I also sit there as a criminal
and I know when somebody is playing with
somebody's mind mm-hmm you know and you
and I both know look what happened two
weeks ago Jesse silhouette that didn't
happen because of his blade as gay that
didn't happen because it was black that
happen because of the pressures of
Hollywood bro sometimes we forget who
the [ __ ] we are
yeah and it happens to all of us at one
time and we catch ourselves and go what
the [ __ ] right I don't like these people
oh no no no no he's right I don't even
like these people
I would not hang out with these people
if you [ __ ] paid me like when you
really come to the shot at the end you
know the Harvey Weinstein is all this
[ __ ] this only happens here innit yeah
because people are willing to sell their
soul you know when I first started going
to have an atomic the acting school I
was a stand-up that was barely making a
living and one day I booked matte matte
TV whatever right and some of the girls
in the class saw it they were all 23 24
27 and they would all come up to being
gone you have an ancient yeah if you
give this an agent will do anything for
you
I mean people want to suck a dick for an
agent and stuff yeah so what do you
think Harvey saw Harvey saw an
opportunity and he took it and my man
the me as a [ __ ] pedophile whatever
the [ __ ] he is
but right yeah you know people willing
to sell their soul it's down yeah we've
seen it happen
thirty thousand times the reason why you
and I are still here is because we
didn't sell ourselves we may not be rich
we may not have a butler we may not work
every day well at least we know who the
[ __ ] we are right and we're not [ __ ]
confused
and then and you've ever worked on a
kids show uh yeah you never see the
mothers yeah it's it's it's it's insane
it's insane it's insane those people we
don't know I got home you have what's
called staged worlds yeah and guys you
don't even want to know what that world
now you know that's a complete different
world with this time that yeah you only
want to get to know because it's it will
do anything any the mothers will do the
parents are ruthless anything and the
fathers are at home working right now
work on a nine-to-five and well the [ __ ]
and that's why a lot of those kids you
know I'm not protected lot of those kids
get [ __ ] destroyed and some of them
that are stars wind up you know dead and
hooked on drugs and you know it is it's
stories that I spoke to Rick Schroeder
years ago and he was telling me he had
good parents and they protected him he
could have been like a lot of his
friends in Hollywood that got [ __ ] up
and destroyed so between the parents the
drug was the pressure start them you
know it's just too much man so what the
[ __ ] you didn't get invited to the
Oscars I was all happy I know it's
unbelievable I know you're going to
[ __ ] ask haha No No thank you thank
you I went to the SAG Awards I went to
the saying Awards um but the Oscars not
everybody gets invited to the Oscars you
the Oscars is very political and you
gotta be I think if you're a member even
if you remember it's like by you know
it's by a lottery now to even get a
[ __ ] ticket maybe a couple of people
that were nominated will get invited but
not everybody from the movie a lot of
the guys I spoke to that were in the
movie it had big party good parts like
me weren't invited so that's just how it
you know I would have been nice to be
there but the bottom line is I was in
the movie in the movies in the Academy
Award movie won the Conn Film Festival
so I mean listen I've been to all these
big award shows except the Oscars so it
would have been nice but you should was
shooting the movie did you think there
was an Oscar no nothing no I just
thought it was interesting I I thought
you know I was only there for like nine
days whatever did my role hadn't worked
with Spike in a long time but I did like
the tone of the movie and thought Adam
driver was interesting John David I
liked him but I had no expectations I
didn't think the movie was gonna be
anything that big until Spike told me
this is like some do the right thing
[ __ ] Nick you know and I'm when I saw I
did the looping furnaces are and I heard
he got into the kind Film Festival and I
said oh it must be good at must because
I almost went the kind Spike had two
tickets
that I [ __ ] up I didn't go huh I
should have my son was like you blew it
you blew it
I couldn't went to the con and walked
that red car I should have just went I
got the plane ticket you know cuz con is
like it's a scene it's like the Oscars
maybe even more prestige in a way but it
won the the camera do you oughta
whatever they call it over there but no
I didn't I didn't know man I didn't
really know it was gonna be that that
you know that kind of movie
some nice is better when you don't
expect [ __ ] like that you know I was
like years ago when my pretty I didn't I
didn't know how my pretty blue it was
gonna be you know legendary show but
sometimes you know what the things you
think that are gonna be [ __ ] homeruns
is never wrong but this was a small came
together and you know when I saw the
premiere in Brooklyn that was a great
night John was there and you know
everybody was like man this is dynamite
it was it was great feeling I mean but
like I say I would I would have liked to
been to the Oscars but I wasn't there so
it's okay I'm still in the movie so in
the movies gonna you know a lot of
people are watching it now and I'm like
finally got his Oscar which is cool I'm
happy for him he's back on he's back in
the game you know it's been it's been a
minute but spike you know he's had a
great body and body of work and you know
it all started for me with him mo better
blues jungle fever I mean it wasn't for
him I might not even be in show business
I mean let's take it about it like I
didn't meet him and I didn't scream
those racial obscenities or whatever he
made me do [ __ ] and who knows I might
have not even become an actor it was
funny how someone gets you started that
starts you and it all started with him
how old were you I was like my late 20s
scars on my [ __ ] late 20s and you
know I went down one night to be an
extra and then I didn't show up the next
night Wow he was asking like what
happened why didn't he come back and
then he called me one day he head of the
blue to do some looping so [ __ ] mo
better blues oh not more bad for do the
right thing and then that's how I you
know that's how I caught his attention
by yelling and screaming this [ __ ]
racial obscenities for like three hours
and he was laughing hard and next thing
I know he put me in a movie so you know
it was mo better blues man I'm with two
Jewish guys we're playing to Jews me and
my brother
Moe and Josh Flatbush you know Denzel
Washington I was like who's this guy Wow
he's [ __ ] good my brother was like oh
yeah this guy is like you know and I was
like I just hope I could do it I hope I
don't suck it was my first movie you
know but I worked hard you know and I
remember after a couple of weeks my
brother goes I had to go back to being
the doorman you don't forget what
happened here don't forget the
experience you had so i won't i won't i
knew like you know it definitely changed
my you know this bike was like I got
something else for your coming something
better than you know next movie and I
was like alright great so that started
the whole [ __ ] that was jungle fever and
then that was like my coming-out party
you know I was like really [ __ ] so
psyched and Pompton we were rehearsing I
had hair cut the serger to Keaney sweat
suit I mean [ __ ] when I was really
like in a zone in that movie I knew
where after that movie I said I right
this is it I'm I'm doing this I'm going
for this no I'm not stopping me now I
was like that really was my you know so
it's always special you know to do
something when a guy that I started you
you know and I mean it's nice to to have
that feeling you know you know the only
thing is you don't pay a lot but that's
how he is but it's okay you know man I
say it all the time how the allure of
this town is not for me it was never the
starting for me it was never the
starting mm-hmm it was just doing what I
want to do I liked I enjoyed comedy
I enjoyed a movie or a TV show from time
to time it wasn't money or anything like
that it was just something I enjoy you
know mm-hmm and still be 56 I still live
here and you don't like Joey I see
you're just no I'm not gonna settle here
I know I don't want to die in California
I want to have a different type of house
me til I want to have a different type
of life I want to be a little slower you
know but the thing that keeps you here
is where
it's Lee or you or me is that everything
to change right and nobody else that
lives like that understands that that
we're here talking today and tomorrow
you might get a show a call to go to
Culver City at 4:30 to read this new
[ __ ] show on ABC and you go in there
and year later it's on Time magazine
it's a cover of this it wins 13 Emmys
and your [ __ ] life changes forever
yeah 57 years old or 23 years old was 38
years old something that doesn't happen
when you just have a very good day job
that if I'm a day job and I'm gonna work
on the movie theater I might get
promoted to manager I gonna change my
life it's a little put a couple buckets
in my pocket and whatever that's why it
deal Laura Laura that really wore that
job away it's my lottery tonight right
your one job away from and you don't
know what job that's gonna be yeah it
could be a movie with Will Smith or it
could be a [ __ ] short film for doubt
Johnny dela Cruz that goes to Kahn and
wins best film sure but that guy that's
doing a pilot NBC that was actually
gonna go with Johnny goon BOTS to play
that part is now gonna go with you
because on the way I heard your voice or
whatever the [ __ ] yeah that thing is
what keeps us here that little that at
all this could change now what do you
wanted to change what do you want to fly
around the world we Prince I don't want
to know that stuff not the sound I don't
have the I don't know but you could know
that maybe somebody puts together a show
that it's gonna be the best five years
of your life yeah and you're gonna do it
from 58 to 63 yep your and then when
you're done you're done
done you're a dog that's what I want
yeah you I want that Bob Darden I want
that and not just the money I want that
that feeling again I want that feeling
like I remember when it I'm never gonna
feel like that when I'm NYPD Blue and I
was young and this and that and
everything was so new so fresh so when I
think back like if sometimes I go wow
did I really did I and that I soak it
all in that I enjoy that I probably did
because I was I was in it
but just that feeling that hi again to
be a part of something that good and to
have that ride I want one good ride
before I [ __ ] go on to wherever I go
in there I mean I'm hanging on that's
what I'm hanging on to you know because
I still got some [ __ ] left in the tank
and I still got some some punch left so
long worst-case scenario would be a
[ __ ] chef yeah you brought some
sauces put some sauce so you know he's
red so maybe I branched out it's okay I
just picked it up from Gelson's okay so
we mass produced it now I'm sampling it
has it has it taste tremendous you know
I went to original Joe's a couple of
weeks ago in San Jose San Francisco
right there was a point where I just
tasted the spaghetti right like well
have the sauce I got some of the
spaghetti right the spaghetti was
[ __ ] delicious good I could taste a
flavor they put water in it they put it
back in the pot and stir the butter it
is nice al dente
show them the color it had good color
too they got the ribbon there everything
just has to be marketed that's it I mean
my mom made an incredible sauce and now
I've developed mine and everybody goes
nuts over it so it's just a matter of
you know getting some the right people
behind it maybe put me in John's face on
it you know even though he didn't make
it but it's all family you know I mean
that's in us you know we grew up with
our sauce was unbelievable my mom I
never could even see how she made it it
just thing like it appeared you know she
didn't brush all the [ __ ] meatballs
with just melt-in-your-mouth I mean but
you know my sauce is people comstock
delicious they come for it yeah I mean I
made it years ago fast lights and this
is light right very nice you'd like to
to Riley I want I want to have the
entire jars he would be yeah he brings
it every time I was thinking buds
another
Oh Nick come over bring so ya know
obviously get sandwiches from the
mingoes but hate that [ __ ] yeah close
some o'clock there [ __ ] it's all right
it's all right
happy that I thought maybe we would just
order a pizza from Joe's yeah GrubHub
whatever I know is I don't think no
other delivery from Sherman Oaks now I
had a big late lunch at the Monica was
not bad I had some oysters today and I
had some [ __ ] seviche
not bad had the oysters are good for the
UH old finger and I am pretty good I'm
saying man I'm [ __ ] oysters they work
just like clams on the half shell you
know work squats why you squat maybe
heavy weight ah man my dick gets [ __ ]
hot dark chocolate a you know tried dog
chocolate no it's good dark chocolate
get your dick hard there's a mulashi up
there by the by the like a a girl I went
to high school with then I went to
Jersey we were all in the same room like
a bunch of guys try some morning I think
of some surprise a happy is still get it
up really because she's single really
are even singing like a why you date she
goes ah
half the guys I date don't get a [ __ ]
hard-on like that's a shame yeah I mean
if you're that young you know I mean the
only thing is you know you know it's a
different kind of harder oh yeah that's
a different [ __ ] life it's harder it
comes you know and it disappears quickly
disappears quickly
wait awful [ __ ] there you go there's no
more [ __ ] hold on ten minutes somehow
give me those families ekend no way
right yeah those twenty year old you
know you it's funny how sometimes you're
driving in the car
mm-hmm and you're at a light and you see
a young couple right like eighteen
seventeen and you look at them you go
dead doing some [ __ ] yeah like I
remember going you know like being I
never in the car like I got into that
young but I got into like when I was 20
21 like that one girlfriend that you
[ __ ] every day twice a day no matter
what she got to Dickens a day he went
out and lived in the Seattle when I did
that one girl I gave her a stab and
every day to keep her in check right
every [ __ ] day I had yeah now I can't
give this now every day not every day
not every day
go get horny yeah I still get dark yikes
you wake up with a hard-on yeah good
yeah sometimes I get horny in the middle
all night sometimes I get horny when I'm
on the computer
yeah like a [ __ ] 3:00 in the morning
in the computer oh yeah sure
it's funny how different things get you
excited now as you get older little
things you know you taste changes you
know you can't plan it you just gotta
live in the moment you know you can't
plan that [ __ ] you know I mean you just
can't plan theirs when it comes it comes
you know Ray Romano special he talks
about that does he yeah special huh I
like that no it was a very good was it
good he's a good standing he's a very
good step 30 years he's a pro well he's
solid
you know he's acting solid yeah you some
good [ __ ] yeah some good [ __ ] yeah I've
even said that show here on TNT I got
hooked on that for a while the men show
with the black dude and the right guy I
got into that show yeah he was even that
violent shirt it wasn't very good I
thought he was good it was great life
and I mean is he gonna be in the
irishman that's it that should be
interesting huh De Niro Pesci Keitel I
don't know what the [ __ ] but she know I
just gonna see it and I don't know I
think Sebastian Maniscalco let's get
some acting work Davison handled for him
good for him he's a good stand-up he's
in the green book which I liked
I thought the green my friend wrote that
bottom you got a piece of that I'll tell
you why when my friend Nick vila velha
Longo wrote it and then I said yeah how
come they used all these like generic
guys they didn't want to use people from
what I heard that were very known and
sometimes they wanted to go against that
not that um no well they use that guy
that what's a guy all the guy in their
name and he was the original Don Johnson
and then Don Johnson took his job
good-looking Italian guy not that goos
married to the chick from my PT blue Oh
Oh Joe caught a Z yeah he said yeah well
Joe was in but Joe was like the only no
Joe's a character I know Joe but I mean
there was all these other guys that were
like you know they were okay I didn't
think they were that memorable you know
I liked the script I thought that Vigo
is a great actor but he's not Italian
you know the movie was a goose it was
all good it was a good enjoyable movie I
liked the movie I thought it was a good
movie yes my friend is loves it he says
one of the best movies I'd was saying
I thought of liver watching one of the
greatest movies of all time but I think
it was a very good move I thought star
was born was very good I mean I mean the
rhapsody movie I thought the kid was
good I didn't love the movie but the kid
was very good in it and so the star born
was good yeah yeah I thought he did a
great job
dice was good and then my brother turned
that roll down that die stood and I
guess John didn't want to do that role
but um but thanks was good but I liked
the movie a Bradley Cooper I mean he's
gotten better and better and better you
know a to play science to Bradley Cooper
and and Lady Gaga
to Italians so I did like the boy saw it
on the big screen
I saw Roma which it was slow I mean
people loved it you know I was autistic
that was that Mexican more dying to meet
it how fun so could on or something but
the movie was was slow but it was
interesting it was beautifully shot it
was in black and white was all about
women I don't know if you saw it Roma
but I love the green book black clansmen
I thought was easily probably one of the
best movies too I thought we were right
there I thought we could have gotten we
could have gotten it too but it was at
least said something in the beginning of
the movie or during the boilers no no no
no you do though I respect you because
you're a student of the game me it's not
the same scene I will be on the small
screen do you know I'm over nothing has
blown my [ __ ] top off in a long time
it's been a while so I got a problem
either I'm living too much in the past I
thought about this no you know but the
other name I [ __ ] came in the store
Sunday night my wife was sleeping and I
went on YouTube and I bought here the
dragon I was just in the mood for Mickey
Rourke right I was driving back up where
okay I'm in the move from Mickey Rourke
it's $2.99
I'm gonna watch an hour of it I laughed
I cried
I [ __ ] giggled my ass off he says a
couple
now the first time my wife's here the
dragon I walked out yeah that's all that
the Fox Theater and Boulder it was I
just moved to Boulder in 1985 and just
been out that week and you walked out I
did well he walks in and tells the
Chinese people there's a new marshal in
town
am I gonna [ __ ] is this [ __ ] punk-ass
[ __ ] Hey yeah he did the Pope of
Greenwich Village nice threaten ensuring
these people none of my clock I got up
and walked out of the [ __ ] movie when
he showed up two years later angel yeah
and it was a little stronger but the
first time I watched you in the dragon I
walked out and then I saw it like a VHS
I worked at a video store they came in
and you had a different feel the second
time oh yeah no I love that's why I tell
you you can't judge a movie the first
time you can watch a movie that you
loved and then the second time you don't
love it as much or that vice versa you
didn't love and then you go wow this is
[ __ ] way better this is like like the
movie the town I watched that movie that
Ben Affleck made 25 didn't love them I
love that movie I love it better than
the movie that he made that he got
nominated Jeremy Jeremy Renner and and
Ben Affleck is [ __ ] great in it
that's a great [ __ ] mood Rick is good
the chick is gaming the [ __ ] cop that
bothers me and that guy he's a bit of a
douche what's his name he plays a good
douche guy he was on that series I
figured Mad Men madman yeah he was great
close the [ __ ] gate I mean I loved
that movie
I loved them I watched it and is a
disappear on him Jon Hamm yeah he plays
a good douchey guy you know he's the
kind of guy you look at him you know I
don't like this guy but he's a good
actor he's a good actor I got to give it
to him and that's a great I tell you a
movie that I love that people don't even
know about I told Michael Curry Oh Lee
fingers have you ever seen fingers yeah
1977 Keitel Michael ragazzo oh my god
you got to see a young Tony Sirico is in
it James Toback wrote and directed it's
one of the best gym browner's in it oh
[ __ ]
you're gonna love this movie fingers
somebody told me about this [ __ ]
great
Luca brasi's and it is a scene where
Keitel collects for his dad he's a
collector is that my
you guys okay he [ __ ] he carries a
radio and he listens to that movie
summertime summertime summertime but he
wants to play piano concert penis but he
but he moonlights as a collector for his
dad and the [ __ ] there's a scene
where it's John's pizzeria on Mulberry
Street and he goes in there and and he
he what he called confronts Lennie
Montana who played [ __ ] you know Luca
Brasi
yeah and he tells him can I talk to you
he goes nah and I know he doesn't mean I
did cuz I gotta talk to you goes and he
takes him in the back and he's like what
a confrontation then we you know Keitel
goes and they're carrying the radio
1970s in the John's pizzeria
you could even google that scene the
[ __ ] scene is look is great I don't
want to tell you how the scene goes down
but it's a good movie it's like it's
like one of the best movies that people
don't know about fingers you were loving
I know it's right up your alley
you will [ __ ] love this more New York
in the 70 and just whatever reason I
found it like at a [ __ ] Costco years
ago and I discovered it a lot of these
movies you watch James Toback he made
the original gambler you guy was -
that's a good movie talk with Jimmy come
Jimmy Carr that's a great more so good
morning but these movies know it's good
to thief that's one of my all-time
favorite move that's a good movie one of
the Michael Mann's one that's not over
the top yeah I love that
that movie turned me into a criminal
that's why you will love fingers yeah
when when that movie came out first of
all that was believable
the one con in 1980 Oh Dave thief one
cop little bit uh uh if I'm right thief
one kind and maybe nobody know about
that movie
no and then the first 15 minutes no
dialogue door for the fall of 81 that
movie came on HBO with the same lineup
with Hollywood nights and a movie by the
name of Raging Bull
Wow so every night on HBO was the same
boring lineup at the end 1:00 a.m. thief
yeah 233 Raging Bull and we would stay
up right we would meet we would so we
would go to Pathmark shop
I have a half this [ __ ] and then go home
and make chocolate shakes and [ __ ]
watch movies and we will lift this me
and my buddy will power lift his
weightlifters yeah so at night we'll
make protein shakes with you raw eggs
you put six eggs in there yeah
wheat germ [ __ ] ice cream we would
get yoked and [ __ ] oh my god we want to
did it one con 1980 I am uttering this
is because the 1981 someone who came out
eating one wouldn't yeah people they
know they didn't know who Michael Mann
was no no James Caan was saying this guy
but they who stole that movie
Jim Belushi did very good greatly Nelson
is phenomenal you ain't the guy frosty
Robert price is phenomenal
the chick is phenomenal she's good too
when he tells her if they well you guys
get out those are out oh behind is one
of the movies that put me over the top
you have this should i do today well
because if the movies very real
there's something about that movie in
him and Jim was the best in Jim Belushi
of a day the best thing he ever did
there Tibet well he walks in there he
tells the guy who's had done to herself
ah I come in here to discuss a business
with you yeah what are you gonna do he's
gonna give me fair anything else will
you slick somebody know you that he
pulls off 25 to his head
he tells a some nice and slowly I am the
last guy in the world you wanna [ __ ] we
want to [ __ ] right let us pretend you
don't know whose money in it right let's
pretend you knows - you know that whole
scene makes my heart ah I love it and
when I go after people like that we got
this problem and as I think the other
guys good - it goes what do you mean
taken to probate take it to probate in
like a name I don't know I call get the
[ __ ] out of here hey call was Dennis
Farina Dennis Farina who I was loved
right well it was first row saw him walk
by it looks at Jimmy Caan yeah it looks
at well I'm with you and he watches what
the criterion collection when he walks
in and he goes you keep this car running
right
he tells Jim Belushi remember the car
it's one of my favorite cars got the
money
joven immediately through her it's the
Eldorado barrettes at work the work was
like the Pontiac LeMans yeah black
[ __ ] barrettes oh I love that car he
shows up there there's another famous
actor in there he goes hey pal and he's
trying to pick up the girls you were
late and that was William Peterson you
remember the guy playing in the band
that's in fact in fact Michael Mann used
them in his next movie which was manhunt
manhunt oh yeah so when she bution from
CSI yeah see ya yes yes yes yes sir this
is 1980 he's the guitar player and then
he was yeah he's the dough he's a dog
guy yeah that comes over right he's like
you know it cuz he shows up lately
[ __ ] hit some yeah haven't he carries
around look like I do sleep it's max
yeah you know what do you think I do you
know [ __ ] thief I might change shoes
like most guys he's like Church cause
like most guys change their brain shows
yeah I wouldn't the joint well he's
looking at it for an answer
I don't care who's never come on to you
did ever come on to your that's right
cuz I'm a true blue collar guy cool blue
tiger guy let's get on with this big
romance secrets you know [ __ ] around
oh man it's a no-nonsense type of
character and yeah you know the read the
scene in the restaurant when they're
sitting there after they adopt a baby
and the Chinese gotta go what's a nice
baby what's named there's no name yet no
name cuz you want to name him after okra
he goes now your name is David David a
guy a guy my son my son is David they
have a good name David good I love that
serious so simple you know and ma'am you
know when they did they [ __ ] you knew
they were gonna do a number on him he
was like you know [ __ ] em yeah I will
have your wife on the streets getting
[ __ ] by [ __ ] important all my god
you will die what it'll be when they'll
bleed them for lunch hamboning
hamburgers you do what I'm sayin say you
end up in the joint for me what happened
to your pal and they talked about acid
and when I was after they stole after
menthol a dragon
that's Jim Kelly I mean his family oh he
didn't give a [ __ ] no at the end when he
goes back dog there's a scene in there
guys when it is shown washing his head
he gets the tally throws in the sink and
he looks at himself in there for 30
seconds then slam just forehead in the
mirror yep and the mirror kind of cracks
and then you see them walked into a
closet yeah you know in real life that's
how you have to you have to be that
discipline
remember when she's like what I'm doing
right why are you doing this this is
over a month is three hundred thousand
you obey her mind read after that you
will be on your own and all this [ __ ]
exactly those type of guys a program
like that that's and I thought age I was
like that's what I made really got to
discipline I made what I need is someone
let's stick this up that's why there was
something very truthful about just the
way they did that movie I don't know and
I'm not a [ __ ] criminal but there was
something about that movie that just
rang so true even when you watch it you
just like wow they really nailed it you
know I met a guy was an electrician by
the long-delayed you loved that movie
he talked to me about alarms and I
became an electricians helper and it was
all to learn how to break into a loss
really my hormone what about that one
that did that the tool that they made a
tool that they may because I wanna make
god yeah that was some [ __ ] tool you
had to draw and then I was always
confused I always thought that you had a
[ __ ] be a safecracker so for years I
was going there with a sledgehammer yeah
for the break things this [ __ ] that's
not true
summer of 83 I made a Westie you did and
he told me there's no how we don't
bracket that's in the movies who told
you this Wesley a Westie guy I had
become friends with him through a friend
of mine and he liked me and he used to
get me jobs and warehouses to case them
out yeah you've got got your job go down
everybody sit on it yeah go down there
case this stuff out because you knew I
was a thief right so you go look for the
one
look for access look for access to the
roads tell me what you see that you
don't like cuz of me he would take me to
places yeah and go what do you see that
you don't like yeah I don't like that
windows too close to the street that
lady is always no wonder you're not
gonna get into that [ __ ] building
that lands always that could see that
[ __ ]
yeah from Holloway so he knew that right
so he told me he's the one that said we
don't break saves so we take the safe
home and then we go to a guy with a
welder and he wells the same soaping
right so that I started doing that I
just thought of taking a hand jack with
me oh really yeah and I would just walk
out with the safe with the hole so I
stole about ten safes and I opened up
about ten of them you did yeah well I
call that skill hole give somebody
hundred to [ __ ] get a well this thing
yes this [ __ ] guy you know like he
will he know someone's an inspiration
yeah like he inspired him well Willie
Nelson he met him in jail yeah you meet
somebody in jail somebody takes care you
get you become a better criminal in jail
oh you do oh yeah you meet you meet guys
that uh the guy that's you at thirty
five forty right you meet him at
twenty-eight you got a five-year bit I
was in a year every [ __ ] day oh okay
he's in New Year everyday when we get
out we'll do this this yeah so now you
learn if you look at that guy that
worked for Pablo Escobar
he learned routes when he went to prison
yeah the guy from Medellin Cartel when
there was a Nazi and like John Lennon
and all that [ __ ] he got better in
prison he was a weed smuggler went to
prison for weed weed and he met do as I
was going with it what are you doing we
got cocaine you get out call this guy
and tell him you got a plane and don't
do it through here do it through that
you know when I got locked up I learned
a bunch of things mm-hmm you learn
little things that most people do not
know right like one thing I learned in
federal lockup before you get sent out
was all those guys were saying the same
thing as dirty as this is I'm saying you
know in movies you see a guy show up
with a briefcase because bumpy's passed
that [ __ ] that
this [ __ ] dude man hey I never seen
anywhere like him
we took the elbows are dead tonight yeah
one for each eyeball he was saying
you're still open
I'm getting there I had a moment there
for a second he was heard that noise
before oh yeah there was somebody stuck
dog yeah I was just standing good good
that's really what I got I gotta hear
you one day come on I'm actor I'm I'm
doing skank first I'm pretty sure about
that yeah yeah well Rappaport stole my
mum my Mikey's doing stand-up now huh
like he was a stand-up he was right and
now he's out there doing it Shane's not
to listen it's crazy there's old market
I know I'm gonna say to you well you see
a guy come up with a suitcase and he
gives it to you and the guy opens up the
suitcase he goes it's good then you take
it and then you tend to band you cut it
and put it a tube and shake it up and
see if it's blue right and you take it
home you know for years I never I never
got in trouble for drug possession or
sales I always kept sales to people I
know right and even if I didn't know you
and I hello oh I always put a cop
uniform on you uh-huh probably does way
when Carl either walks into the hospital
and he goes I don't know but that guy
doesn't look like you should be wearing
my a blue suit that's how you know a cop
is a suit you look at him and go put
that suit on them if it's a cop it's a
cop
is it trust your brain your instinct and
I'm the meeting not one guy but I talk
to multiple guys that didn't know each
other right you know multiple different
guys that showed me their paperwork what
they had been arrested for you know
possession of ten kilos of cocaine and
[ __ ] and there was one guy that told me
that was a couple of times of told me
stories about he goes I go why would you
sell him that much if he didn't do
Coconino what are you talking about this
guy was going wine for lying with me
right these guys go line for line with
you Wow the one guy was saying I'm a
coke shooter mm-hmm this guy would go
shot-for-shot with me
but they take you once they get you on
camera and they get the audio and the
ten cops come in they handcuff you they
got you yeah so what they do is they put
that cop into rehab yeah they clean him
up and he shows up on his cologne when
his system is clean you're sitting there
going he can't be a cop I did Harold
with him I did coke with him they're
like you're a criminal
well believe you yeah but I know tons of
guys that said the same story the same
[ __ ] I got high with them shot coke if
they ate pills I ate pills you know it's
just a different animal when you're at
that level a federal agent you gotta
throw down yeah when you're a local guy
maybe some kid will say old nickel bag
but for me to sell you two kilos we're
gonna hang out for a couple of weeks
right let me get to know you let's make
some runs you know I'm saying so that
[ __ ] don't happen but the [ __ ] Lord's
prayers were answered this week finally
you decide to start releasing a podcast
yeah finally you know Lee still talks to
that guy with the baseball games and
stuff yeah I've been talking to him oh
you have yeah they liked it and
everything I think it's a great thing
there was just no money to be made and
that's why we didn't pursue it anymore
because right it's a sad lay away from
my kid you know blah blah and there's
not even a little bit of money you gotta
sit there with a bucket right you know
and then hope that somebody gives you
five bucks yeah I don't like that I
don't mind making a free video if it's a
free video but two hours of me sitting
here talking about a UFC fight or
baseball game it's got to be part of the
package
yeah something you know it could work if
it's part of the whole father yeah you
know what this thing maybe we'll watch a
few games with some people together
parts of games and implement that into
the show you know even though baseball I
can't it can't just be about baseball
but we can take snips and clips from
[ __ ] you know but that I think the idea
that was good it just needs to be more
it wasn't flushed out enough I think to
make it like I know what we did it we
tried it for UFC and there's an app like
I download the app and there was like a
couple of steps yeah and you have to
eliminate a couple of those steps thank
you
people are used to clicking fast they
want to click yeah like once or twice a
P no no I was listening I went on CC
Sabathia and this guy Ryan ruko in New
York I did a podcast with a man a and
they were fascinated by the idea so it
would be great if we had like an app to
channel we we could have a do a game
once in a while uncensored uncut where
you know you don't just curse the curse
and you say I [ __ ] mother you know you
watching a game really unstuck and care
you know and Cece said bagless man that
would be great you know Andrew Cole goes
yeah that would be great to do a game
where you're like in a real you know
situation with a real fan like me and
maybe a few guys and just off the cuff
watch a game but commentate on it in an
organic real way for like a real like
give them that option like if they want
to watch a baseball in a different kind
of way instead of this generic way and
they were like that could be [ __ ]
great something like that they liked the
idea they were saying this design new
app area but they're doing just boxing I
think right now they signed that they
were out of England I don't know Daz and
we heard about them Canelo signed with
them and it's a new network but I mean
listen I'm gonna start with this try to
build it up and I mean I've been fooling
around with this stuff for the last few
years but it's it's about time that I
give it a shot and go at it every week
and try to [ __ ] you know bring mean
it to Touro to the [ __ ] place every
week and something find my own [ __ ]
thing you know I mean it's about time
I've been talking [ __ ] and everybody's
like ma'am we'll just do it just do it
so it's time and I got Nick Nick who's
like behind it in this other guy it's
show time was supporting it so maybe
well we'll get a little love you guys
like you Mikey wraps everybody's like
you know give me that little push and
you know might as well [ __ ] do it why
not well I got to lose I'm happy you
came out of the map you brought the
sauce thank you buddy Lee's done take it
home take it home home put it on some on
some pasta
that's for you but you know don't let it
go to waste because that's [ __ ] you know
yes absolutely
I wish I knew I could pasta make it I
don't know how to work that's well a boy
mr. nahdi used his [ __ ] stove well
okay I don't [ __ ] know how do you
catch it nah she does it I don't [ __ ]
know it's stove you get a good stone I
got a great stove I just don't know what
the [ __ ] it is you know made though I
know yeah well then your wife doing yeah
I thought I'll say he'll be making us
some spaghetti if you don't mind
no what'd you think about the fights the
other night I thought the fights were
[ __ ] good yeah what we had a bad
night huh
yeah they gave me that I'll bill dust
yeah he [ __ ] [ __ ] okay Benny when
you get the game you could see you can
wrestle huh badass current combined ask
Rica wrestle huh yeah it's gonna be
interesting to see how this same thing
I'm gonna make them fight again or not
yeah with some really good fights in the
guard but yeah I'm not that much into it
that much you losing your taste for it
maybe five [ __ ] dollars go rob
somebody
[Laughter]
I want to thank Nick tutorial good luck
with the podcast keep us posted
well no I want to thank you guys I want
to take the flying Jew the Christ killer
but most importantly you guys that
listen to the podcast in the church
family for supporting us and following
us every week like I told you I'm gonna
be in Houston it's all sold out Buffalo
sold out and Pittsburgh April 4th to the
6th that's all I got for you right now
what I do want to do is uh the church is
brought to you by listen you know how
hard it is to find a good employee for a
company thank God I got a lead but a lot
of people whether your business is small
or a big business is hard to find
qualified candidates takes a long time
too many applicants but there's an
easier way zip recruited hiring is
challenging but there's one place like I
said that you could go that makes hiring
simple multiple job site stacks of
resumes a confusing review process but
today hiring can be easy and you have to
go to one place to get it done
zip recruit at comm slash shirt listen
zip recruiter sends your job to over 100
of the web's leading job woods but they
don't stop there as applications come in
zip recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match
zip recruiter is so effective that 80
employers who post on zip recruiting get
a quality candidate through the site
within the first day you understand me
one day
zip recruiter what I'm love doing right
now is this the family the church family
gets a try zip recruiter for free gratis
who got nothing I don't care if you have
a little donut shop I don't care if you
have a big mechanic I don't care if you
have a payment company of 600 employees
listen zip recruiter is the way to go
for you so what I'm going to do is the
church gets exclusive that's it go to
zip recruiter for free it's free right
now zip recruiter go super cool Tom
slash Church CH you are CH that's zip
recruiter calm slash Church CH you are
CH I'm gonna get you the best thing
you've done in your whole life as far as
your business concern go to zip
recruiter dot-com slash church the
church is also brought to you by Robin
Hood listen while other brokers should
charge up to $10 for every trade Robin
Hood doesn't charge any Commission fees
so you can trade stocks and keep all of
your profits Robin Hood is an investment
that lets you buy and sell stocks ETFs
options and cripples or Commission free
plus there's no account minimum deposit
needed to get the party started so you
can start investing at any level that's
simple intuitive design of Robin Hood
makes the investing easy for newcomers
and experts alike it's that simple view
easy to understand charts and market
data and place a trade in just four taps
on your smart phone
listen in four taps you could place a
trade on your smart phone you can also
look at view stock collections such as
the 100 most popular who's owned by a
woman that type of stuff with Robin Hood
you can learn how to invest in the
market as you build your portfolio
discover new stocks track your favorite
companies and get custom notifications
for price movements so you never miss
the right moment to invest I got two
people my wife is on Robin Hood and my
duck and my friend from the fourth sixth
grade and McKinley school not Bergen
says he loves Robin delivers it's a
listener and he went on Robert he's been
back
for years and this guy loves Roblin so
Robin Hood is giving a listeners of the
Church of what's happening now a free
stock like Apple for the sprint to help
you build your portfolio did you listen
to what I'm saying to you with Robin
Hood you can learn how to invest as you
build a portfolio so right now when you
do me a favor
cuz Robin Hood has given all these a
free stock like apple for the Sprint to
help you build your portfolio sign up at
church dot Robin Hood com
sign up at church Robin Hood dot-com
kick this [ __ ] mule East a black have
a great weekend
see you tonight at the show eight
o'clock [ __ ] stay black